완전
럭셔리하게 건물을 올리고 있는 거
같습니다 이겁니다 아
엄청나죠
정말 투자를 잘했어요
법인 명의로 산게 아니라 개인 명의로
사셨어요
[음악]
제가 오늘은 일전에 제가 할인 건물
촬영하다가
치킨집
치킨 업체 사옥에 대해서
준비하면 좋을 것 같다는 좀 생각을
하게 돼서 제가 오늘 아침부터 엄청
알아봤어요 한 10개 업체 정도를
제가 어디 위치에 사옥을 가지고
있는지 오늘 좀 설명을 드리도록 하고
그리고 개인적으로이 중에서 빌딩
투자를 제일 잘한 업체도 같이 좀
설명을 드리도록 하겠습니다 일단은
가맹점이 제일 많은 데가 bbq네요
bhc랑
교촌
매출액 순위를 이제 보면은 1층이
이제 교촌치킨
매출액이
4,358억 이렇게 되어 있는데 제가
기사 좀 몇 개 더 찾아보니까
매출액이 좀 더 높더라고요 그냥 뭐
대략 추정치
정도라고 참고하시면 좋을 것 같습니다
2위가
bhc가 4천억 정도
bbq가 한 3,200억 그 다음에
푸라닭이 한 1,400억 그다음에
처갓집 양념치킨이 한 900억 정도
멕시카나가
730억 그다음에 노랑통닭이
730억 정도 되고
페리카나가 한 449억
후라이드 참 잘하는 집이 한 360억
깐부가 한 220억 정도 되는데
근데이 표에 빠진 것 중에 하나가 그
호식이 두마리치킨이 빠졌더라구요
그래서
호식이 두마리치킨이 뭐
2020년 21년쯤 제가
봤을 때는 한 500억 정도 됐거든요
아마 한 후라이드 참 잘하는 치킨집
위쪽에 있지 않을까 아니면
페리카나보다 좀 더 위에 있지
않을까네 이렇게 예상을 합니다 그래서
각 업체들이
어떤 사옥을 가지고 있는지 한번 좀
본격적으로 보겠습니다 일단 첫 번째로
교촌치킨인데
교촌치킨이 그
판교에 사옥을 짓고 있더라고요
완전
럭셔리하게 건물을 올리고 있는 거
같습니다 그래서 올해 준공이라고
하는데 위치는
성남시 수정구
금토동 이쪽 일대고
지하 4층에 지상 11층 그래서
연면적이 무려 4,200평 정도
됩니다
특히 업계 1위인만큼
굉장히 큰 사옥을 짓고 있고 그
다음에 두 번째로는
BHC 사옥이
따로 없더라고요 매입한게 제가 확인은
안 됐는데 지금
롯데월드타워로 좀 이전한다
그러더라구요 그래서 19층으로
이전한다 그러고 그리고 이제 뭐요
기사에 따르자면 보증금 20억에 월
임대료가 2억원 수준이래요 그래서
관리비가
약 한 7,500만원 정도이고 보증금
제외하고 연간 한 33억을 이제 임차
비용으로 사용한다라고 합니다 아웃백도
최근에 인수했더라고요
직원수가 많이 늘어났다고 합니다
그래서
롯데월드타워로 이전해서 사용을 할 것
같고
와 워리어 정도면 임대료가 2억이면
진짜 쎄네요 그 다음에 bbq는
문정동에 있어요 사옥이
가락시장역 바로 앞에
그 패밀리타운 아파트에 같은 블럭이
있어요 그래서 8번 출구 앞에
지금요 건물입니다
BBQ 그래서 BBQ 사옥은
2002년도에 매입을 했어요 대지가
161평이고
연면적이 한 1,100평 정도 그리고
지하 3층에 지상 9층 건물입니다
91년도에 준공
했구요 대부분 제가 보니까 그
치킨 업체들이 다 송파 쪽에
밀집돼 있더라고요 그래서 아까 뭐
bhc도 그렇고 bbq도 그렇고
페리카나도 이쪽이 있더라구요 그리고
프라닥은 여기
양천향교역 대로변에
6층 7층 8층 9층을 사용하고
있고요 그리고 처갓집은
용인에 있어요네 용인에 여기 있죠
처갓집 사옥입니다 그 다음에 멕시카나
멕시카나가 최근에 건물을 사서 지금
역삼동에 건물 짓고 있어요 그래서
제가 맨날
출근할 때마다 보고 있는데
원래 이제 송파
쪽에 있었어요 여기 송파역
인근에
원래 이제 사옥이 있었습니다 그래서
여기 멕시칸 아빌딩
보이죠 여기 송파 사옥에서
역삼동으로 이제 이전을 했습니다
그래서 역삼동 건물 부지를 164억에
샀어요
도곡 1동 주민센터 사거리
인근에 있습니다 건물을
지금 짓고 있어요 그래서
멕시카나 신사옥 신축공사
아마 조만간에
준공이 될 거 같아요 그래서 제가
조금도 좀 찾아보니까 이겁니다 아
엄청나죠 여기가 그 상업진 아닙니다
3종이고
여러 인센티브를 좀 받아 가지고
지하 4층에
지상 10층으로 건물을 올리고 있어요
그리고 대출을 꽤 받았더라구요 그래서
지하 4층에
지상 10층
연면적이 한 상황 면적이 한 384평
엄청납니다 그래서 저는
약간 준공되고 나서 모습이 되게
궁금해요 이때가 21년도 7월달에
이제 첫 삽 한다고 했으니까 지금
거의 다
된 거 같거든요
멕시카나는
강남의 사옥이 있습니다
[음악]
그리고 노랑통닭
노랑통닭은 그냥 이제 임차로 들어가
있는 거 같아요 중간에 또 이제
엑시토 한글로 제가 알고 있고
그래서 여기 선릉역
인근에 이제 건물에
임차하고 있는 것으로 알고 있습니다
그리고 페리카나는
서울에 따로 사옥은 있진 않고
계룡시
계룡시에 이렇게 되게 큰 공장이
있어요 그래서 여기를 이제 사옥으로
그리고 후라이드 참 잘하는 집도
매입은 하진 않았어요 그래서 저희 그
청담동에
한성자동차 있는 건물 여기에 이제
임차하고 있는 것으로 예상이 됩니다
그리고
깜부 제가 봤는데 깜부가
정말 투자를 잘했어요
깐부가 이제 이쪽에 있거든요
여기
아까
봤던 그 후라이드 참 잘하는 집
뒤쪽에 이제 되게 좋은 도로에
청담동에 사옥이 있습니다
깐부치킨
이게
2019년도에 샀거든요 근데 전
매도인이 그 유인촌님이었어요이
청담동 건물을
2019년도에 매입을 했고 그때 한
120억 정도 대출 받아서 147억에
샀습니다
굉장히 잘 샀어요 그래서
그때부터 이제 가격이 또 폭등하기
시작했거든요 그래서 지하 2층에
지상 6층 건물이고 99년도에 지은
건물이고 대지가 156평에 연면적이
422평입니다
연면적도 굉장히 크고 저는이 건물을
깜부해서 정말 너무 잘 샀다고 생각을
합니다 그리고 여기 지금 이면에
매각되는게 평당한 뭐 2억 중반대
매각이 되거든요 그래서 그거 감안했을
때도 지금 시세는 거의 한 400억
정도 될 거 같아요
깜부가
굉장히 좀 투자를 잘했습니다 제가
보니까 그리고
번외입니다 번외인데
호식이 두마리치킨이 그 리스트에 없긴
한데
호식이 두 마리 치킨도
2015년도에 여기 강남구청역 앞에
있는 그 건물 그때 이슈가 굉장히 좀
많이 됐어요
여깁니다네 호식이 두 마리 스킨
여기 간판 보이죠
호식이 두마리치킨
그래서 심지어이 건물은
법인 명의로 산게 아니라 개인 명의로
사셨어요 개인 명의로 사셨고
2015년도에 330억에 샀습니다
대출을 약 한 140억 정도
받았습니다
지어진지 얼마 안 된 상태에서 이제
매입을 했었고
지하 3층에 지상
17층 건물입니다
내지가 132평이고
연면적이 무려 1361평입니다
엄청나죠 내 상업지에 있는 건물이고
그래서 저는 지금
투자한 거 중에는
호식이 두마리치킨이 거의 탑클래스로
되게 잘했다라고 생각을 합니다
물론 이제 그 교촌이
성남시에 사옥이 훨씬 면적이나 규모로
봤을 때 더 크긴 하지만 232
정도는 될 거 같아요 그리고 깜부도
너무 잘했고
매출로만 봤을 때는
다른 업체들이 많이 있지만 부동산
투자에 있어서는 그 잘한 거 같습니다
그때 당시 워낙 또 싸게 샀고 그
주요 지역에 되게 잘 투자해서 좀
가격이 많이 오른 그런 사옥이라고
보시면 될 것 같고 많은 분들이
치킨을 굉장히 좀 좋아하는데 이런
것도 보면서 아이 업체들이 좀 뭐
어떻게 하고 있구나 뭐 이런 것도 좀
관심 가져주시면 좋을 것 같습니다
오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요 제가
이거 뭐 찾다 보니까 좀 이렇게 할
만한
업종들이 좀 있을 것 같더라고요
그래서
혹시 이런 업종들간에 뭐 이런 사업이
궁금하다라고 하시는 분
댓글로 좀 남겨주시면 제가 파악을 한
다음에 또 이렇게 한번 촬영해 보도록
하겠습니다 그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지
하고요 다음 시간에 또 뵙도록
하겠습니다
감사합니다